اصدرت المغنيه العالميه مادونا الفيديو
الموسيقي الاصلي لاغنيتها امريكا اللايف
والذي تم الغائه قبل عشرين عام بسبب محتوى
عن الحرب في العراق الفيديو يظهر عارضات
بازياء عسكريه وخلفهن تظهر شاشه كبيره
تعرض مشاهد لنساء واطفال من ضحايا الحرب
وسلط الفيديو الضوء على مشاهد الحرب شديده
العنف كما اظهر صورا حقيقيه لضحايا الحرب
الحقيقيين فضلا عن مشاهد تمثيل العراقيين
ومذكورين الاطراف وقيل ان هنالك مشهد حذف
من النسخه الاخيره من الفيديو تظهر شبيه
الرئيس الامريكي وهو يحمل قنبله يدويه
يشعل بها سيجارته لكن المشهد حذف لكي لا
يتسبب في اثاره جدل بالمجتمع الامريكي
مادونا صرحت انها صورت هذا الفيديو قبيل
الحرب على العراق لكنه لم يعرض بسبب
حساسيه الموقف واحتراما للقوات المسلحه
يعرض الفيديو بعد 20 عاما من الحرب
الامريكيه على العراق
[موسيقى]